Now, you might be asking, why in the world are we talking about logic?
I mean, certainly it makes sense to talk about faith.
Certainly it makes sense to talk about truth.
But why would we take an entire week out to talk about something so strange
in a Bible study about logic? Well, I think it starts
with what the writer of Hebrews says in the last part of chapter 5 and the early
part of chapter 6. It says anyone who lives on milk, still an infant,
is not acquainted with the teaching about righteousness.
But solid food is for the mature, who by constant use have trained themselves to
distinguish good from evil. Therefore, let us leave the elementary teachings about
Christ and go on to maturity. Peter says much the same thing about leaving
the idea of spiritual milk and moving on to maturity.
Paul says be transformed in the renewing of your minds and put off the old self and
put on the new self, imitate God, have a mind like Christ.
And even Jesus said we need to worship God with
all of our heart, with all of our soul, with all of our mind and with all of our
strength. It's clear throughout Scripture that logic has a place and
that is a tool that shouldn't be considered a threat.
In fact, it's an incredibly useful tool.
I mean, after all, Jesus said it.
And in fact, you'll find the Bible study this week that Jesus even demonstrated it.
We'll see a couple of strange things throughout the study.
And one of those things is this weird term that you see in Latin called reductio ad
absurdum.
I'll say that again, reductio ad absurdum.
And essentially, it's just a fancy Latin word that means reduce to
absurdity.
It's that simple. And even that seems kind of confusing.
So let me give you an example that should help with your students to explain this
kind of strange concept.
When I was a kid, ever so often I would skip school.
And this one time in particular, my dad caught me.
So naturally, he asks me, why did you skip school?
Well, I had this genius idea, this genius logic that I came up with.
And I told him, well, all my friends were doing it, so that's why I did it.
That makes sense. That made perfect sense in my head.
And I kind of stood there waiting for him to make a response.
And he didn't take very long before he said, well, if all of your friends jumped off
a bridge, would you too?
Essentially what my dad was doing, whether he realized it or not, was taking my
argument, drawing it out to its natural conclusion, which is absurd.
And that's essentially what reductio ad absurdum is telling us.
And when we see Matthew 22, it's Jesus engaging in this same sort of logical
analysis in his confrontation with the Pharisees.
So instead of fearing logic,
our goal is to get students to embrace logic and actually get them to understand
that logic is a vital tool in the search for truth.
Remember what we're doing here throughout this process, and we talked about this
when we talked about truth, is that students are looking for what is true.
We want students at the end of this process to be able to look truth squarely in the
face and actually see Jesus. So logic is going to help them get to that point.
So in their intro experience, we want them first to actually see that in their
relationships. So students are using logic in their relationships to
search for truth in those relationships, and we want them to do the same thing with
Jesus. So take Paul, for example.
If you look through Acts, whether Paul's in Corinth, whether he's in Ephesus,
whether Paul's in Thessalonica or in Athens, what you see is that Paul is constantly
using logic. He's reasoning from the Scriptures about helping them understand
who Jesus is, what he's all about, what salvation means.
Essentially, Paul uses logic through and through in almost every single one of his
arguments as he's traveling on his missionary journeys.
So the idea is we want to invite students into a space where they can be curious,
not only ask the questions, but sort of logically think through these things and add
an intellectual piece to their faith.
So as you dive into small group, you're going to ask what looks like a really simple
question. Should faith make sense?
That's kind of tricky, right? There's a little bit going on here that we need to
address because there's so much about Jesus that does not seem to make sense.
There's so much about our faith that doesn't seem to make sense sometimes.
But as we think through, as we use logic, as we actually engage
intellectually with our faith, there's a lot we can figure out and God has given us
the tools to do so. And really this is much of the Pharisees' problem.
This is what we see from our question one and their motivation to get after Jesus.
And they just didn't really get it.
But I want to take a second and really touch on question three because this deals
with potential arguments against Christianity and whether or not these arguments
make sense.
Be careful here, but answer these honestly or talk about these honestly because
there are some arguments out there that sound pretty good, that seem to make some
sense. But that doesn't mean that they're logical and doesn't make them right.
It just makes them additional arguments.
But a lot of them are worth talking about.
But make sure, gauge your students.
Make sure you know where they're at.
If you don't think your students can handle it, then that may be a question you
might want to sidestep for just a minute and then come back to it when you think
that they're ready. So as students depart for this week, leave them with this
question. What about your faith doesn't make sense to you?
And challenge them with what it's going to take to spur them on to a mature
faith. Because remember, Jesus calls us all to clear and careful thinking.
The same kind of thinking that Jesus demonstrated.